Some people have noticed for the comments in some of the latest computer file videos that there's a new option for viewing them instead of
Just being 1080p and 720p
You've now got
1080p50 what on earth is 1080p 50
The number after the P
refers to
the frame rate how many
Different frames per second are there in the video sequence that you see now before because we shoot in the UK Sean will be shooting
most of the time at 25 frames per second so yeah
So my hand isn't running at 25 frames per second, and you'll see it sort of jerks a bit compared to
My face, which is speaking at 50 frames per second
Let's back up a second actually what what do we mean when we talk about frame rates or frames per second?
Well when things move when I drop this pen for example
It's a continuous motion it starts off here
and it falls through all the positions in space until it hits the table and stops now when we
capture that to display on video on film
We don't capture all the motion what we do is we sample it
Just like your sample audio into lots of discrete segments if you actually look at a piece of film you can start to see this
Quite easily what there here's a piece of 16 mil film you can see that actually you've got lots and lots of individual
Images and each of those images we refer to as a single frame and when you project you this fear
we literally shine a light through that I hope you projected onto the screen and then a
Bit later when we move it up show the next one and so on and so by doing that
Fast enough you get the appearance of motion projected either on your computer screen or at the cinema
I mean we're used to thinking about an image as being a two-dimensional thing when we're making that into video
We're also extending that effectively into another dimension
Time and so at the beginning we have this image at time zero, so this is time along here
And then it's some other point that's per. There's no point five seconds of course in the real world you've got
XY and z directions on the computer screen it's flat so we forget about the Zed
And then you have XY and of course we have time as things move about
around it so that Y here and
X here, and we can talk about these things at being in different positions at different time so at t
Zero this thing here is a bit off the bottom and a half way across at t nor point five it may be
That the left-hand edge of the image, so it's changing position
Now you could describe how that moves you can say I want to move this from here to here the computer could draw all
the movements actually when we shoot something
With video or film we do something different. We break it up into discrete samples
Just like when you make digital audio you take the waveform and break that up into discrete samples
We do the same with video so we break the video up like this
So we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
different frames for that half a second and each of those
frames
Just represents the image at that point in time so at point zero we take it a photo and we've got
This one are then at time no point 5 over 12
Which would be naught point naught 4 we take another photo and then at no point naught 8
We take another photo and so on so our frame rate the number of frames per second is just literally how many
Times are we going to divide this block up per second so in this case in half a second block
We've got 12 different gaps
So this would be recording at 24 frames per second and that is the standard frame rate
That's used for movies interestingly the reason they went for 24 frames per second is all to do with money
When they introduce a sound into the cinemas they needed to increase the frame work from what they're using in the past which is about
16 or 17 for something like some of the early silent movies
to something where they could actually record the audio and get the decent quality of sound and
24 frames per seconds was the cheapest frame rate basically that could get away with so they use less film
So it cost less to shoot something, but they all still had decent quality sound
Completely arbitrary decision and actually if you look at all the frame rates used in TV and video
Things they've all been made for similar reasons
So for film it was reducing the amount of film. I had to shoot of TV
It was down to the frequency of the mains system, but we'll come back to that later
What's the ideal frame rate the best one to use is that if this wasn't down to cost? What's the best friend?
infinity if you use an infinite framerate your samples
It'd all be zero width therefore
you've captured every single bit of motion actually the best framerate is a difficult question to ask because it's
Since highly related to what you're trying to capture if you think to audio you need a sample rate
Which is twice the maximum frequency you want to catch due to Nyquist and Shannon's laws?
So you have around 48 kilohertz is what's generally used for audio because it's well over twice the frequency you can hear about 20 kilohertz
24 frames per second was chosen for cinema because it's generally good enough for capturing the motion
It's only when you get things going quite fast from rotating that you actually see it the classic example is you sometimes see in films
Car wheels and things or things like that that's spinning. You'll suddenly see them start to go the opposite direction
Then as they get bit faster. They'll start going the right direction again
this might sound like a silly question for me because I'm the one who's chosen to shoot at 50 feet, but if
24 is adequate to capture motion, and I've been shooting at 25, which is even more frames per second why does 50 look so different?
Right was actually so this is the interesting thing is actually if you were to look at the frames
Captured at 25 P and captured at 50 P side by side for the same time for most things
They would look or might sit identical the problem isn't with the capture so we can ignore capturing it now
Because that's pretty much the same whatever frame way we do the problem comes to when we try and display it
particularly when you try and display it in a cinema if you think about a piece of film
So they're all these individual frames and the way a classic film projector works is you have a light behind it?
But the problem comes I want to display
The next frame in that we have to move the film up
Mechanically so the next frame is in front of the light and projector through the lens onto the screen now
You've got mechanical properties here. You have to move into an exact position so you've got a core mechanism
With just that but you can't still be transmitting the light to the screen
Otherwise you'd get the blur as the film moved up
and it would just look like a blurring mess as it went and was you actually have to physically display the whole image and
The way that it does that is there's a spin disk which covers the frame-up so you get a bit of black?
Between on the screen, and then you get the next one and so you've got image then black then image
Then black that image then black
Turns out if you do that around 24 frames per second
It looks horrible it flickers like mad your brain can still see the flickering on the screen
And you don't see the motion you start to see it as a set of separate
images
So the way we got around this when they did build the first film projectors
Is that rather than displaying each frame once they displayed each frame try so you show frame one
covering black show frame one again
Give it a black move it up to be frame two showing frame two covered with black so frame two so you're actually showing
48 frames per second, but you've actually only got 24 discreet frames. You're just showing each of them twice
Now what happens is the brain?
sometimes looks at that and thinks
What on earth is going on and I've got a demonstration over on the computer here
So I'm going to play this back. You will suddenly see that it appears to be two circles even though on every frame
There's only ever one circle on-screen so if I set this playing
You will see you get the appearance as it moves across as if there's two circles sort of overlaid on top of each other
And so one of the things that gives film its look is
That you have these two frames laid on top of each other so the projectors show thing the frame
Twice or even three times on some projectors to get around the flicker problem and because of the mechanical nature of them now a television
Works in a slightly different way in television particularly a CRT like the monitors behind me
Are a single dot which is flying?
across the screen from
left to right
Across the screen and moving down so it's only ever a tiny single dot every other minute at a time
But it scans from the top left through to the bottom right and it sort of zigzag pattern
Every 50th of a second so it appears to display whole image if you slow it down you can actually see
The image being built up on the display now
They have the same problem if they just had the CRT display at 24 frames per second or 25 frames per second then
would look horrible
You'd see the flicker so they displayed them at
50 fields per second and the reason they chose 50 or 60 is to deal with the frequency of the mains in the UK and
the US and in different countries in the UK the mains frequency works at 50 Hertz and by choosing your frame rate that matches that
You remove a possibility of getting interference?
on-screen or rather you remove the possibility of the interference being visible on screen, so it's a
Technical consideration again that made 50 in the UK or 60 in the u.s.
a good choice for the frame rates, so they update the image on the screen every 50th of a second of
Course because it's all electronic and not having to move physical pieces of film you can now capture
Each of those things 50 times a second and so actually we have a higher
Motion rate and because we're not showing everything twice if we come back to the demonstration what I've got is two
videos now this one is the same one we had before this time is at 30 frames a second two of them 24 and
This one is at 60 frames per second what we see if we've run both of these is
That this one strobe still although it's slightly less because it's at 30 frames. We got double imaging
But this one is much smoother because we've got the same images sampled a lot of thing and the brain isn't having to work out
And I'm seeing this image twice or what's the motion doing? It's only seeing each image once and so it looks right?
This is why film still looks like film when it's shown on the television
the film is shot at 24 frames a second and each of those frames is shown twice or
Three times to get the frame rate up to 50 or 60 times per second when it's placed a still get that double imaging which
Is what gives film is look not the fastest 24 frames a second. It's a bribe
It's a nice fret of the fact that things are shown twice. Why don't we go to 50 frames per second things don't look like?
So yes, I mean when we get to shooting at 50 frames per second or 60 frames per seconds or even higher things look
The things stop looking like film and look more real because the motion rendition as we saw on the demonstration is more realistic
You're seeing each frame once and so your brain is able to work out saying
Oh, that's the circle moving from left rather than thinking hang on
What on earth's going on here with this motion and so on it can actually understand the motion because it's similar to what it sees
in everyday life
And if you increase it to say 100 120 or even up to 300 it would be even more like and you'd have even more
realistic looking video
The problem comes if you then try and display that image
Directly on screen because things are moving between each of those things you get these sort of little
Zigzag effects because actually this letter T. Here is moving horizontally so each time. It's captured the lines at a different point